hello everyone welcome to the show
i'm always honored to be on this show
and a part of this show but today is
supremely exceptional for me because
today is a very special episode because
we're celebrating nurses all show
and the best part is our entire audience
is full of hard-working selfless nurses
so thank you for coming today
thank you
nurses are the ultimate drew brenner's
and that's why
i am so excited to be teaming up with
johnson and johnson to honor them today
that's what this show is
they have supported the nursing
profession for 125 years supporting the
mental health and well-being of nurses
as well as championing their impact and
innovation in health care because
lifting nurses up lifts us all up and
today
is for you and because of you
so our first guest not only cares for
her patients but for her fellow nurses
there's nothing she doesn't do so please
take a look at tiana's story
[Music]
hi my name is tiana morano i'm a wife
and mom of two from ronkonkoma new york
i've been a nurse for the past 12 years
now i always knew that i wanted to get
into the medical field my great-aunt was
a nurse in world war ii and she started
a first aid clinic on the shinnecock
indian reservation where my dad grew up
and she inspired me to become a nurse i
actually started a nursing program later
in life at 27 and i graduated at 29.
i've had many jobs with a nurse i
started on a medical surgical unit then
i worked as a camp nurse and i worked as
a school nurse taking care of kids this
year i was board certified as a family
nurse practitioner i currently work in a
sub-acute rehab facility in 2013 i
wanted to connect with other nurses and
give us all a sounding board so a friend
and i created a facebook group called
long island nurses it started growing
more and more and nurses actually
started getting recruited from the group
for jobs
when the pandemic hit i started hearing
awful stories from the nurses on the
page who were working on the front line
it was and still is a very hard time for
us
i know how hard we work how we skip
breaks how we work overtime so
i knew that giving back to nurses
especially during a pandemic was
something that needed to be done
just to give everybody a sense of
community and to keep going
i turned the group into an official
non-profit so i could continue giving
back i've raised money for scholarships
i've held fundraisers for nurses and
i've even put my own money in to help
nurses in the group in total we've given
away thousands of dollars to long island
nurses we have 5 000 members right now
and i want to see it keep growing i'd
love to have every single nurse on long
island in there if i could
nurses aren't appreciated the way they
should be and it means so much to be
able to give back to them i'm really
proud of nurses and what they're doing
right now despite the challenges they
are up against and i hope to be able to
continue to support them all because we
are in this together
please
[Applause]
tiana
you get to see the direct effect of what
you do and what is your hope for the
future of long island nurses in your
dream scenario where does this build and
go to
i just want it to expand i want to be
able to reach every single nurse on long
island and beyond nurses deserve to be
uplifted they do so much for society
they do so much for everybody so they
deserve something in return and that's
what i try to do
and you've made such an impact
on those in the long island nurses group
and guess what we have a few of them
here today to surprise you so stand up
everyone
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
all right thank you ladies so much for
being here to support tiana and promote
the long island nurses may i ask holly
how
it has been to be a part of tiana's
group how did it impact you so i am a
very proud school nurse on long island
and
i came to find the group right when the
pandemic started because i knew we were
going to turn into a virtual format and
i wanted to figure out a way that i
could contribute when schools went
virtual and within four days i was on
the lines doing swabbing on the
drive-throughs across long island and it
made me so fulfilled and not only that
opportunity but then i kept networking
with other members in the group and i
secured another position and i do
telemedicine still to this day and the
group's just so much offers a safe space
for professionals to come together and i
just hope that you realize
the impact that you've made for me the
impact that you've made for nurses on
long island far and wide so thank you
[Applause]
well thank you
holly i really appreciate that sentiment
that's the part of that motivation you
know that you know how does that make
you feel
well uh it really touches my heart i
mean just to see
people
that i'm actually affecting nurses so it
just really it completes me
can i do a little something for you
tiana
yes
[Applause]
for your kitchen i'm personally gifting
you my entire beautiful appliance and
cookware line and i also
recently if you don't mind we can come
over here because i also recently
launched flower hair tools and i want
you to have them all
so that you can take care
of yourself
i believe that beauty is on the inside
but it is a feeling and if we can feel
good
then that is also somewhat medicinal and
so for that reason
for your self-care i am also sending you
home with this entire huge selection of
makeup
from the flower beauty line
now
those are the things that i make and
that i can contribute
but to help long island nurses continue
to grow our show is also going to donate
25 000
to the organization
oh my god
but i want to also thank our friends
because that's not all our friends at
johnson and johnson were so inspired by
your work
especially in your education they're
going to donate 25 000
so the national students nurses
association in honor of your
organization to help nurses continue
their education and this is just a
starting point we know there's so much
more that you need to get things done
and j j is committed to partnering with
the nursing community to see real change
so you can learn more about johnson and
johnson and supporting nurses at
nursing.jnj.com
to join in and foster this ever so
important community so thank you tiana
morano
thank you to the long island nurses
thank you to johnson and johnson
and we will be right back
[Music]